lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
usemos todos nuestros conocimientos
todas nuestras habilidades en
trigonometría en identidades
trigonométricas para calcular dada la
información que tenemos aquí para
calcular la longitud de esta línea
amarilla de este segmento de recta que
va de aquí aquí te invito a que le
pongas pausa al vídeo e intentes hacerlo
por tu cuenta antes de que lo hagamos
juntos supongo que ya lo probaste y
quizá te diste cuenta que esta línea
forma parte de un triángulo rectángulo
que tenemos aquí donde está que estoy
marcando sería la hipotenusa nos están
dando los ángulos alfa y beta pero
podríamos combinar estos ángulos para
formar el ángulo alfa más beta y así
podríamos relacionarlos con este que
sería el cateto opuesto recordando la
definición de soca tohá
todas que nos da las funciones básicas
de trigonometría seno cateto puesto
sobre hipotenusa así es que en este caso
tenemos que el seno de alfa + beta que
tenemos aquí es cateto puesto sobre
hipotenusa la hipotenusa vale 1 entonces
el seno alfa + beta sería simplemente
este cateto opuesto que lo que estamos
buscando así es que el seno el seno del
ángulo que en este caso sería alfa
más
beta es básicamente lo que estamos
buscando seno de alfa + beta es la
longitud de esta línea que tenemos aquí
seno de alfa más veces igual al cateto
opuesto sobre la hipotenusa la
hipotenusa es 1
así es que seno de alfa + beta es igual
a la longitud de este segmento así es
que otra manera de plantear el problema
original es como calculamos el seno de
alfa + beta y aquí se te podría ocurrir
recordando sus identidades
trigonométricas que existe otra manera
de expresar seno de alfa + beta existe
una identidad para seno de alfa + beta
la identidad establece que seno de alfa
+ beta es igual a
seno de alfa que multiplica a coseno de
beta más ahora intercambiamos argumentos
coseno de alfa que multiplica
seno
de beta voy a poner una línea aquí para
no confundirnos así es que si
necesitamos calcular seno de alfa + beta
y pues expresado de esta manera lo que
necesitamos ahora es calcular seno de
alfa coseno de beta coseno de alfa y
seno de beta y albert estos triángulos
nos damos cuenta que si podemos calcular
esos valores hagamos eso seno de alfa
seno de alfa es igual al cateto opuesto
0.5 sobre hipotenusa que es 1
así es que seno de alfa es simplemente
0.5 aquí tenemos que esto es 0.5 coseno
de beta beta es este ángulo que tenemos
aquí y vemos que la definición 12 no es
cateto adyacente sobre hipotenusa en
este caso con 93 0.6 sobre 1 por lo cual
cose 9 es igual a 0.6
esto es 0.6 vayamos ahora a calcular
coseno de alfa coseno de alfa es igual
coseno de alfa es el cateto adyacente
que es raíz de 3 sobre 2 sobre el
hipotenusa
qué es uno esto es raíz de 3 sobre 2
coseno de alfa esto es raíz de 3 sobre 2
finalmente seno de beta seno de beta es
igual al cateto puesto que es 0.8 sobre
1 así es que esto es simplemente 0.8
aquí aquí lo voy a poner mejor como
cuatro quintos para que pueda ser
después esta multiplicación así es que
esto es cuatro quintos que es igual a
0.8 creo que va a ser más fácil
simplificar aquí esto y todo esto a que
es igual
esto es igual a 0.5 por 0.6 esto de aquí
es igual a 0.3 ya eso le vamos a sumar
esto que tenemos acá cuatro quintos que
multiplica a raíz de tres sobre dos
dividimos entre dos arriba y abajo y nos
va a quedar dos raíz de tres sobre cinco
con lo cual tenemos aquí 0.3 más 2 raíz
de 3 sobre 5 básicamente esta es nuestra
respuesta aunque no me gusta la forma
que se obtuvo finalmente aquí tenemos
una fracción aquí tenemos un número
decimal vamos a combinar esto para
obtener una sola expresión racional para
esto vamos a expresar 0.3 como una
fracción así es que esto es igual a tres
décimas más dos raíz de tres sobre cinco
lo vamos a escribir como 4 raíz de 3
sobre 10 vamos a hacer esta suma de
fracciones esto es igual a
4 raíz de 3 sobre 10 pudimos hacer la
suma directamente pues tenemos el mismo
denominador así hemos concluido